hi isaiah how are you
i'm doing just fine thank you for taking
my call sure what's up
all right so uh there's no debate that
tithing is important and at least 10
percent is what we're
required to do but i just got to a point
where my tithing has gotten
larger and i've also noticed that
through my local church
there is a statement at the bottom that
shows how much i tithe and
i'm having a moral issue here on whether
it
is morally acceptable to claim what i
tied on my taxes
okay i think do you mean spiritually
yeah yeah and so you're just checking
your heart and going
am i doing this for the wrong reasons
yes
that's a good question i'm glad you're
asking that of yourself i actually
wrestled through that one uh many years
ago myself and i kind of did it at the
same point you did when my tithe got a
little larger and i went whoa
that's some money i always wrote it off
when it was small i didn't think
anything about it but it was a big deal
it was a little bit bigger and i went
yeah that's a that's like a big tax
write-off
here's the thing i think you can ask
yourself in prayer honestly before the
lord
if you are doing this because you feel
like it is
one of the disciplines one of the
things we do in our spiritual life that
god tells us to do because
it's good for us in other words am i
being obedient
or am i tithing because of the tax
write-off
99.99 of the time someone who asks this
question
doesn't have the problem that's the one
who doesn't ask who might have the
problem
the very fact that you had a tender
enough heart to even ask the question
tells me you're not doing this for the
tax write-off am i right
yeah okay if you're not doing it for the
tax write-off
then it comes down to uh if i take the
tax right off
have i done something wrong when the
intent of your heart was you didn't do
it for the tax write-off
you did it because giving is a part of
your faith walk agreed
yeah okay then it comes down to me to
stewardship
and in my mind to be a good manager of
money
one part of that is to keep the
government's hands off of as much of it
as possible
because they are not good managers of
money so sending them
any money that i don't have to is by
definition a bad manager of money
and so it is it's beyond uh
it is in my mind once i got there
i said to myself i would not be
uh spiritually correct
to not take the right off yeah
because by sending them the money that
they when they misbehave with it is a
bad
bad use of god's money uh i'm not
managing his money well by sending it to
someone that's wasteful
right when i don't have to yeah now i
wouldn't lie about it i wouldn't cheat
and i'm not go and i have
incredible integrity on my taxes it's
ridiculous how much integrity i have
uh every stinking little dollar and
piece of cash and everything is counted
we don't let
anything slip under the table
not because i'm afraid of an audit but
because i want to be honorable before
the lord
and have integrity about my taxes but
integrity also includes paying as
little in taxes as the law allows
because they're bad managers how's that
sound
that sounds a lot better
[Laughter]
but i have run into people and doing
what we do and chris you probably have
to
and usually it is where there's some
size to the to the giving
that the reason they're giving is for
the tax write-off which by the way is
bad math
but also it's really bad spiritually
yeah
and then sometimes i run into people who
are giving because they want to be
noticed
yes and that's you know i want my name
on the building
or i want you know i demand this or i
demand that now we put our name on a few
things when we did giving
but uh but it wasn't like that was our
was not again it was not our motivation
when your heart yeah
isaiah you're in the right place buddy
um and i think you know as your income
grows
the dollar amount is going to continue
to grow and you're totally fine to be
able to claim that on your taxes as you
move forward
let me give you another prediction okay
i say well i got you
a guy who asks this question
is managing the money well uh
because you're sensitive to what god's
use of the money is and are you in his
will
are you doing that that makes you an
excellent manager
and i will give you a prediction that
your money will grow
because you're an excellent manager the
parable the talents tells me that those
who manage well will be given more
to manage and those who don't manage
well
are given less to manage and
actually that's god yeah and so
there's a wealth inequality thing for
you right there that'll mess you up
well and he'll also be very aware of how
the church is using the funds
uh and what they're doing how they're
impacting the community and so
your heart's in the right place bud yeah
very good i love that question
i haven't had that one in a long time
thank you for calling in with that you
know chris i'll take that step further i
want to continue that discussion a
minute
because one of the things i find is um
and you you and i have both observed
this you see if you agree with this
statement that people who have a
very noble reason a higher calling
so to speak for handling their money
well
have a more of a tendency for handling
it well i think i would completely agree
so in other words if i want to change my
family tree so i'm doing this for the
good of my kids so that my kids don't
have to grow up i grew up poor
some guy says i didn't but i mean i grew
up middle class but
if you grow up poor and you say well i
don't want my kids to have to go up that
way that's a higher calling
that's a nobility it's not selfish it's
not i want to get wealthy so i can get a
car
right it's not wealthy i want to get
wealthy so i can go to
uh st lucia you know that's not that's
not your reason that's a fairly
shallow reason it's an okay thing to do
but if that's all the bigger
reason you have you're not gonna go but
but probably the
highest calling the most noble calling
are when
a person of faith says
i've got to do this because this is what
god requires
i'm not it's not my money i'm managing
it for him and i've been doing a bad job
managing his money
and i've got to straighten my act up
when they have that kind of motivation
those are some of the people who will
sacrifice the deepest
in order to win they're the ones their
budget is clean
they're not cheating there's no ish ever
comes up in their language
because the nobility of their why is so
high yeah
absolutely and it that's the gauge
that's the thing that keeps them on that
track
and won't let them veer off you know
they are intentional
and uh that's uh i remember having that
awakening
uh some 15 16 years ago you know the
other thing that does
for those of you out there that are
people of faith okay um when you take
that position
then you're no longer taking a poll
from your parents who turn their nose up
or roll their eyes or your friends who
go
oh yeah well nobody ever gets out of
debt you're like
i'm not taking a poll because i'm doing
this for you that's right i'm doing this
for your approval
i'm not even doing it for my own
approval i'm doing this because i feel
like this is what god requires
that's right because the borrower is
slave to the lender that's right
and people don't get a vote you know
just
your need to please other people goes
away it goes away
in tandem with you having that level of
higher calling it sure does
and that's another element that causes
people to win when you are trying to be
a people pleaser
and everybody in your freaking life has
a vote yeah
and you're trying to impress them you're
trying to make them think you're cool
you're you're doing whatever you're
keeping up with the joneses or the
instagrams or the
kardashians or whatever it is you're
trying to be that person
you are never going to have any money
that's right you're going to be broke
your whole freaking life
and you know part of not needing to
please other people sometimes is having
something bigger to please
i like that and that that's uh you know
i
i have uh seen that with my fellow
believers
the ones who who say okay i've got to do
this because this is what god says to do
and i want to stand before him and hear
well done
good and faithful service when i when i
manage his money i want to
feel him smiling by the way i did it
with my generosity with my diligence
it causes you to get a will it causes
you to get life insurance
it causes you to be on a budget it
causes you to get out of debt it causes
you to buy things
more carefully and wisely it changes
everything it does change it all
and it's so worth it